and each day at this year they're
averaging a hundred and ten points again
ratio and over seven assists forever
eternal that good that is about twice as
good
[Applause]
from the field and James Harden has not
missed the shot those are things that
each practices every single day there it
is again there it is again
[Music]
nice
babbu say he knew right where eros was
going with that ball he picked it off
James just devastating stepping back
behind the three-point line put the
moves on draw the bow Baylor bear there
James again takes it to the metal drop
set
[Music]
[Applause]
watch this drop-off pass right here to
tart black who does something with it
look at the reaction by James Horton he
doesn't care if he scores 1:45 left to
play in the game Harden turns the corner
again lays it up and Annie hasn't missed
folks
there he goes three seconds down to two
second
[Applause]
he's got that clot in his head party
with 25 points in the first half
and missed only one shot doing the
rockets of the second best offensive
rebounding team in the league so they
got a reason with the freezer
he's a second half gun look their loss
had been a good job by Harris and Harris
had it blind it's like a volleyball game
two more shooters we're gonna be a lot
better the Rockets go to James Harden
that's it
he just has to look first shot it's only
the 12th shot that James has taken
inside he's in the game trying to set a
pick for James he does Allen had no
chance and young rookie from Texas Wow
even one of guys right on top of it
James Harden
[Music]
who's doubting capella one when harden
has a double-double this season they're
gonna go to nine and one is just a few